il n'y aurait pas de Turquie celle
laïque et occidentalisée du père
fondateur de la nation Mustapha Kemal et
celle islamistes et orientalisée dirigée
d'une main de fer par Récept Taipe
Erdogan il s'agirait en réalité d'une
même entreprise nationaliste menée à
marche forcée à deux époques différentes
c'est la thèse défendue par ce
documentaire réalisé par Nicolas
grimoire et écrit par Jean-François
Colissimo et maintenant quel cap pour la
Turquie au lendemain de la réélection de
récepts hyperdogan nous allons en
débattre maintenant avec nos invités
présents aujourd'hui sur ce plateau de
débat doc avec vous pour commencer à
mettre une selle bienvenue vous êtes
économiste éditeur journaliste et
politologue votre dernier ouvrage
co-écrit avec Pierre-Yves venin
s'intitule Le National capitalisme
autoritaire une menace pour la
démocratie publiée chez Bleu autour on
citera aussi vous concernant la nouvelle
Turquie d'Erdogan du rêve démocratique
dérive autoritaire c'est d'actualité et
c'est un ouvrage disponible aux éditions
La Découverte Ariane Bonzon est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste et essayiste spécialiste de
la Turquie vous collaborez notamment
pour slate.fr et le Monde diplomatique
votre dernier ouvrage s'intitule lui
Turquie l'heure de vérité il est publié
chez empreintes et puis en fin avec nous
Guillaume Perrier bienvenue à vous et
vous êtes reporter au service
international de l'hebdomadaire Le Point
et ancien correspondant à Istanbul
c'était pour le quotidien Le Monde votre
dernier livre coécrit avec leur marchand
a pour titre les loups aiment la brume
il concerne les réseaux déployés par
Récept et hyperdogan en Europe et il est
disponible aux éditions Grasset je me
tourne vers vous avec ce résultat obtenu
donc à l'occasion du second tour de
cette élection présidentielle turque
Récept à hyperdogan réélu avec 52,
les 2018 depuis l'élection la révision
conditionnelle a été en 2017 et il est
commencé à être en œuvre avec l'élection
présidentielle de 2018 il n'y a pas de
Premier ministre c'est pas le régime
français présidentiel il faut bien c'est
un peu à l'américaine mais avec pas de
contre-pouvoir tous les pouvoirs sans
contre-pouvoir et et et les ministres ne
sont pas responsables devant le
gouvernement il n'y a pas de votre de
confiance du Parlement etc sont des
secrétaires d'État grosso modo et donc
là il va y avoir une continuité une
continuité qui va être marquée par par
plusieurs choses d'abord on dit toujours
le régime présidentiel voyez Brésil il a
pu s'en sortir etc mais bon Sonara
n'était resté que quatre années au
pouvoir n'avait pas eu le temps
d'institutionnaliser un régime
autocratique tu as hyper douanes et
depuis 20 ans au pouvoir et surtout la
dérive d'autoritarisme qui s'est former
en une autocratie c'est depuis 2010
depuis 11 plus exactement depuis les
élections troisième élection de
législatives vous l'avez eu 49% des voix
et cette dérive autoritaire s'accompagne
d'un deuxième facteur qu'on doit pas
négliger c'est que tu as hyperdoine
certes a eu à peu près les mêmes
pourcentage de voix que 2018 quand il a
été élu aussi à de 52,5 réélu une
première fois j'ai élu une première fois
troisième élection présidentielle avant
d'être
auparavant il était premier ministre
mais son parti à perdu des voix il a
retrouvé les voies le pourcentage de
35%, c'est ce qu'ils avaient eu en 34
34%. et donc désormais tu as hyper
douane et son parti a besoin
contrairement aux années 2000 du renfort
du soutien de son allié d'extrême droite
nationaliste et ça lui suffisait pas il
a ajouté une droite nationaliste
islamiste très dur contre les femmes
contre les droits des femmes et cetera
le fils de Abakan et puis une partie de
gisboula kurde qui est
ultra islamiste et en même temps
ultra kurdistes si vous voulez oui je
crois que le grand victoire la grande
victoire c'est plus que ardoise c'est
l'ultra nationaliste qui a gagné lors de
ces élections comme lac vient de
l'expliquer armée tin cell on a des
parties nationalistes dures des parties
islamistes pas seulement d'ailleurs dans
la majorité au pouvoir du côté de
l'opposition aussi il y a un certain
nombre de parties nationalistes voir
islamistes et là ça va être intéressant
de voir ce qui va se passer au niveau du
Parlement même si cette Assemblée
nationale à remettre l'a dit c'est pas
elle qui a le pouvoir le vrai pouvoir
crdon qu'il a mais enfin il peut jouer
de cette sensibilité si je puis dire
ultra-nationaliste qui se trouve aussi
dans l'opposition donc là on a vraiment
un parlement qui est
ultra-nationaliste islamiste et on l'a
jamais vu et de droite si avec tout ce
que ça veut dire des dérives de la
droite radicale la droite on s'étonne
beaucoup que la campagne se fasse sur
des problèmes d'identité mais la droite
radicale et pas seulement en Turquie
mais la droite radicale quand il y a un
problème économique et social qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait elle pose les problèmes de
valeur de d'identité etc et ça ça va se
faire encore plus d'autant plus qu'à
tout un discours anti-européen
antioxydantal qui risque de continuer
aussi donc là on les choses sont assez
claires sur ce plan là oui bah je crois
que les pour paraphraser un petit peu ce
qui vient d'être dit les équilibres
politiques en Turquie se retrouvent
toujours dans l'entourage d'air douane
c'est à dire kerdohane constitue
toujours une majorité autour de sa
personne mais c'est dans la petite cour
qui l'entoure qu'on va retrouver les
équipes politiques propres aux dernières
élections et là effectivement ce qui est
notable c'est d'abord la continuité sur
depuis 2015 2016 et cette période où le
nationalisme est le socle
identitaire de son pouvoir
mais on une radicalisation encore plus
forte que ces dernières années comme
vient de le souligner Ariane il y a un
équilibre interne avec les plus
nationalistes des nationalistes et les
plus islamistes des islamistes donc
aujourd'hui on a une alliance à
l'extrême droite qui est vraiment à
l'extrême droite du spectre politique
légal
erdoine ne pourra pas polariser encore
plus sauf à sortir du champ légal pour
le coup mais on aura du mal à polariser
encore plus la politique c'est à dire
que on a on a dit à quel point la
Turquie était polarisée coupée en deux
en deux blocs pour et contraire de one
c'est effectivement le cas mais c'est le
produit de la politique qu'il a lui-même
appliqué pour toujours maintenir une
majorité plus simple de son côté et
c'est une c'est vraiment la manière dont
il construit son pouvoir en permanence
et là on va voir une espèce de de
recomposition de de l'entourage du
cabinet pour coller je dirais assez ce
nouvel équilibre on en est plus à ce que
nous a la maîtrise documentaire une
coupure de ce pays entre les kemalistes
et les erdoganistes on peut dire les
choses comme ça
évidemment une coupure il y a une
coupure mais il y a aussi il y a aussi
des passerelles évidemment il y a aussi
une forme de continuité on a vu le
candidat cinanohan le troisième homme
ultra nationaliste par exemple naviguer
un petit peu entre les deux donc il y a
évidemment les choses sont plus
complexes et aujourd'hui hardwan a
évidemment cette base islamiste
conservatrice religieuse anatolienne
très importante pour se faire élire pour
arriver au pouvoir mais pour tenir le
pouvoir il a aussi ce pilier
nationaliste avec l'extrême droite
delubries donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui
Ardouane incarne aussi ce que dans les
années 80 on a appelé la synthèse
turquoise islamique qui était une
idéologie politique assez proche des des
généraux de la gente militaire qui a eu
le pouvoir au début des années 80 en
Turquie et qui est
de pouvoir qui repose sur ces deux
piliers l'islamisme et le nationalisme
ardogan aujourd'hui et autant l'un que
l'autre et dernière question peut-être
sur la situation politique intérieure le
principal opposant
d'Erdogan c'était mal killitch Daru il
était à la tête d'une coalition
réunissant six formations politiques
dont une formation politique
cette coalition elle a un avenir demain
en Turquie la coalition procure ne
faisait pas par la partie procure ne
faisait pas partie de la coalition
officielle il soutenait le candidat mais
il faisait pas partie de cette n'ayant
pas présenté elle-même de candidats mais
il se présentait cette coalition on sait
pas parce que c'est une coalition
hétéroclite et à l'intérieur il y a à la
fois la droite nationaliste il y a un
parti islamiste anti-corruption seuls
qui s'opposent à erdouane
essentiellement sur les questions de
corruption et non pas sur les questions
de de valeurs morales et puis il y a la
droite la droite libérale qui a quitté à
quiépé qui a quitté erdan l'ancien
Premier ministre le ministre de des
finances mais on a constaté que les
lectorat de ATP n'a pas suivi ces
figures libéraux ils sont beaucoup plus
reportés sur le la droite
ultra-nationaliste quand ils ont été
mécontents alors ce cette coalition
hétéroclite nous ne savons pas
exactement ce qui va se passer la seule
chose qui risque de les tenir ensemble
peut-être dans les mois qui vont venir
c'est les perspectives des élections
locales au mois de mars parce que on a
constaté que dans les grandes villes sur
les sur les 30 grandes villes le le la
coalition d'opposition ou quand
majoritaire sur la grande majorité des
cas est majoritaire donc du coup s'ils
veulent gagner ou s'ils veulent garder
les élections les mairies des grandes
villes d'istanbulent dans le carat
d'Antalya de Adana
a fortiori les candides les parties
doivent rester unis pour donc le seul
le seul quoi durant si vous voulez reste
la perspective des élections municipales
d'ailleurs tu as eu peur douane le jour
de son discours de victoire ce qu'on
appelle le discours depuis son balcon il
n'était pas depuis il était sur le sur
l'autobus il a immédiatement
immédiatement mis en perspective les
élections municipales lui-même en disant
il faut regagner les villes d'Istanbul
donc du coup il a remobilisé son son
électorat là-dessus et je crois que
l'opposition aussi va rester une nuit
mais par contre nous ne savons pas ce
qui va passer du côté du parti procure
parce que ce parti est-ce qu'il va
continuer en tant que partie est-ce que
le Conseil constitutionnel la cour
conditionnel va
dissoudre le parti va interdire le parti
il va il y a attention interne aussi
dans le dans le mouvement de gauche
par rapport à par rapport à quelque
chose
probablement il va y avoir une
recomposition la seule chose je
terminerai c'est que en Turquie quand
même il y a une division à deux de la
société on le voit géographiquement la
carte électorale et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ceux qui ont voté
grosso modo pour christarolo votre à
l'intérieur du bloc mais ne bascule pas
de l'autre côté et ceux qui ont voté
grosso modo pour erdouane votre à
l'intérieur du bloc il diminue acuper
diminue mais c'est ses alliés qui
augmentent donc il n'y a pas de passage
de d'un bloc à l'autre et c'est ça qui
est le plus peut-être intéressant à
étudier en Turquie rien de raison parce
que peut-être surpris les observateurs
occidentaux avec cette réélection
d'Erdogan c'est comment peut-on réélire
Erdogan compte tenu de la situation
économique intérieur de ce pays voilà ça
c'est un des premiers chantiers qui aura
devant lui Erdogan on va tout de même
rappeler que au moment où nous nous
parlons l'inflation en Turquie est
aujourd'hui environ de 40 entre 40 et 44
% elle a été même jusqu'à 88 %
d'inflation au mois d'octobre 2022 avec
les conséquences évidemment que cela
signifie pour la population turque ça
c'est le premier chantier qu'il a devant
lui comment a-t-il fait pour être réélu
alors telle situation économique nos
esprit rationnels se disent c'est pas
possible je veux dire les frigos sont
vides les gens ont un pouvoir pain perdu
énormément de pouvoir d'achat
l'inflation est énorme enfin bon comment
se fait-il qui qui puisse encore voter
pour lui et puis il y avait aussi le
problème du séisme vous rappelez le
double séisme du 6 février avec 50 000
morts des tas de blessés 3 millions de
personnes sans domicile et qui ont mis à
jour font le roi a été nul c'est-à-dire
qu'on a vu quand même une politique
d'urbanisation clientéliste assez
corrompus enfin
il y a eu quand même des bonnes choses
sur du d'une politique
urbaine qui a été positive aussi du coup
du gouvernement il faut voir que un
certain nombre de lotissement etc ne
sont pas effondrés mais enfin l'image
quand même aux général c'est que il y a
eu des appels beaucoup Erdogan dans
cette région et pourtant et pourtant ils
ont voté pour hardwan donc qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que le frigo
vide ne suffisait pas à voter
contrairement et que Erwan les a nourris
d'autres choses les a nourris d'un
discours
antioxydantal anti-européen victimaire
mais en même temps très fier et
souverain donc ça c'est très important
et puis aussi le parti acupé et l'État
lui-même ont été mis au service si vous
voulez une relation clientéliste avec
cet électorat c'est à dire qu'il faut
pas croire non plus que ils n'ont pas
des dividendes qui ne reçoivent pas
quelque chose où il y avait cette image
de
erdoine qui distribuait de l'argent bon
à un moment à des enfants à des gens
c'est une image évidemment qui qui ne
pas être reproduite à l'infini mais qui
veut dire quelque chose c'est à dire je
suis là quand même pour pour vos besoins
je les tailles là le parti est là et il
y a quelque chose qui s'est inscrit qui
met une partie de la population en tout
cas la moitié de la population dans
cette relation de dépendance vis-à-vis
du parti et de l'État il y a eu un
miracle économique lorsque
Erdogan n'était devenu le premier
ministre il y a maintenant 20 ans
c'était en 2003 il était face à une
situation économique extrêmement
difficile aussi à ce moment-là et il y a
eu un miracle économique Erdogan est-ce
qu'il est capable de reproduire ce
miracle économique compte tenu de ce
qu'on sait de la situation économique du
pays aujourd'hui alors miracle
économique je ne sais pas il y a eu en
tout cas l'application d'une politique
économique très stricte à l'époque sous
la supervision du FMI ça avait
d'ailleurs été lancé par Kemal dervich
qui était le Miss de l'économie avant
cardoane arrive au pouvoir donc
erdoine a bénéficié d'un contexte
d'assainissement de l'économie qui
effectivement lui a permis de tirer
bénéfices de plusieurs années de
croissance et de redressement très
spectaculaire le PIB des Turcs a été
multiplié par 3 en 10 ans ça c'était
pour la première décédée de son pouvoir
et puis après on a vu
l'économie suivre un petit peu la même
courbe que la démocratie dans ce pays
c'est-à-dire une plongée assez lente et
aujourd'hui on est revenu à des niveaux
qui étaient ceux du milieu des années
2000 donc la situation n'est pas bonne
aujourd'hui elle est le produit de la
politique d'erdouane parce qu'il faut
quand même rappeler cette politique de
taux d'intérêt négatif par conviction
religieuse essentiellement il a appliqué
une politique à la banque centrale qui
est intenable et qui provoque
aujourd'hui cette inflation et cet
appauvrissement donc voilà donc miracle
économique je dirais qu'il y aura pas de
miracle tant que la politique économique
d'erdoine restera imprégnée d'idéologie
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui donc la
banque centrale ne sera pas indépendante
puisque l'une des institutions qui est
placée sous la coupe du palais et ce qui
provoque évidemment
pas mal d'interférences donc et pourtant
et pourtant a obtenu une nouvelle
majorité à l'élection président oui
parce que effectivement on est trop
rationnel et on pense que les électeurs
votent en leur année conscience en
fonction de critères rationnels mais ça
n'est pas le cas en Turquie on vote
d'abord selon des réflexes passionnés
identitaires
et puis que Marianne a très bien rappelé
Ardouane est devenu l'expert s
clientélisme depuis 20 ans c'est comme
ça que sont partis a conquis les masses
dans tout le pays donc c'est comme ça
aujourd'hui aussi
s'identifie comment il est symbolisé
comment il y a eu une augmentation de
près de 50% du du salaire minimum à
quelques encablures du premier tour de
cette élection président donc ce n'est
pas une augmentation
d'Erdogan
les plus ruraux par exemple je
présentais le clientélisme la Kep est un
parti qui officiellement je ne sais pas
on ne sait pas si c'est vraiment vrai le
chiffre mais officiellement à 11
millions d'adhérents sur 85 millions le
pays 11 millions d'adhérents parce que
en Turquie les adhérents sont
directement inscrits dans une registre
de la Cour de cassation donc du coup on
connaît le nombre d'adhérents officiel
de tous les partis
11 millions d'adhérents signifient en
grande partie des personnes qui
en montrant leur carte ATP
peuvent bénéficier où ils ont
l'assurance de bénéficier parce que ça
veut pas dire que les autres ne
bénéficient pas mais c'est une image
qu'il donne le parti en disant en
devenant membre de parti vous allez
bénéficier des aides sociales des des
priorités tous les réseaux clientélisme
d'abord il faut le voir de ce côté là
deuxièmement le réseau clientéliste des
petits et moyens d'entreprises le taux
d'intérêt négatif dont a parlé et
Guillaume permet effectivement aux
petits témoignages d'entreprise
d'accéder à des crédits qui sont
inférieurs autour d'inflation ce qui
alimente l'inflation par ailleurs mais à
court terme ça permet et puis troisième
facteur qui est important c'est que la
crise économique l'inflation
montre son impact majeur dans les
grandes villes parce que les loyers
augmentent parce que les prix
l'inflation alimentaire augmente alors
que dans les petites villes de province
dans les villages on sent moins la crise
économique parce que on a moins cette
dépendance du loyer du transport du
dépenses culturelles on va pas au
restaurant donc on se rend pas compte
que le prix a augmenté dans les
restaurations etc donc on met du coup la
population dans les grandes villes ont
réagi à la crise économique dans toutes
les grandes villes comme je t'ai et
devant mais dans les villes de province
dans l'Anatolie centrale ça ne marche
pas et puis troisième chose pour le
tremblement de terre
les électeurs ont pourquoi tu as hyper
douanes à accélérer les élections après
le tremblement de terre il avait déjà
l'intention il a maintenu parce que
faire des élections dans 6 mois cela
signifie ne pas pouvoir faire une
campagne exclusivement sur des promesses
mais faire une campagne sur des
réalisations or il a totalement fait une
campagne sur des promesses en disant
vous allez avoir un million de
constructions qui vont être immédiates
font fait dans un an et donc les gens
ils ont comme rien à souligner c'est
l'État est devenu un parti état et il
est au service de erdan et quand elle
doit distribue de l'argent c'est comme
il distribua en même temps l'image de
tout ce qui est en location ce n'est pas
l'état qui donne c'est l'état Erdogan
qui donne donc c'est personnifié et
c'est identification entre la personne
le parti et l'État c'est le propre de
l'autocratie et évidemment que je t'ai
donné pas crédible par rapport à ça le
chapitre des promesses il y avait
celle-ci ramené le taux d'inflation à un
chiffre dans les années qui viennent on
verra ce qu'il en sera à l'avenir on
attend aussi beaucoup
évidemment de ce que sera la place et la
politique extérieure de la Turquie après
cette réélection il cette réélection a
été saluée par toutes les capitales
mondiales avec des intérêts évidemment
divergents dans ce satisfait site
exprimée à la fois côté occidental côté
russe côté chinois notamment à quoi
faut-il s'attendre dans les mois qui
viennent concernant la politique
étrangère turque alors sur la
congratulation quand même on peut
s'étonner alors je sais que c'est un
exercice très formel et très codé enfin
il y a pas eu un mot sur cette campagne
électorale qui a été parfaitement
inéquitable c'est ça n'était pas une
campagne démocratique ces élections
certes le processus d'élection a été
c'est tenue de façon relativement
démocratique mais la campagne électorale
les deux des deux rivaux si je puis dire
sont partis sur des bases totalement
différentes par exemple qu'il est déjà
relou l'opposant n'a eu que 32 minutes
de télévision pour le mois d'avril
tandis que erderer 32 heures et tout ça
comme ça à l'envie et la répression dont
tu as fait l'objet une grande partie de
la population turque depuis ce fameux
coup d'État de une partie de 2016 voilà
une partie des cadres en particulier
Kurdes qui savent mener qui sont des
politiques qui savent faire campagnes
etc sont en prison ont été les mères ont
été démis remplacés par des
administrateurs etc donc il y a pas eu
un mot pas eu un mot dans les dans les
félicitations et ça montre quoi et ben
ça montre le malaise et la complexité de
gérer
erdouane qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'erdouane
je parle plutôt de l'Occident et de
l'Europe voilà un ardoise qui membre de
l'OTAN qui loiture qui est
officiellement encore candidate de la
Turquie de l'Union européenne pardon et
elle a une attitude finalement qui
s'inscrit plutôt dans cette espèce de
Sud globale qui veut prendre sa revanche
vis-à-vis de et vis-à-vis de l'Occident
elle s'inscrit plutôt du côté des Russes
et des Chinois il y a un discours
tellement anti impérialiste etc et donc
on voit on voit le malaise si vous
voulez de l'Occident qui est quand même
extrêmement lié à ce partenaire certains
disent incontournables en particulier
pour la gestion des réfugiés vous savez
qu'ils ont tous ces réfugiés syriens et
il y a cette hantise de l'Europe de voir
encore des flots de réfugiés débarqués
sur sur les côtes alors vous savez qu'il
y a eu ce deal en mars 2016 conduit par
Madame Merkel de
l'Europe donne 6 milliards d'euros à la
Turquie pour qu'elles gardent les
réfugiés sur son sol ce qui est un talon
d'Achille pour pour l'Union européenne
parce que le jour il veut réouvrir ses
portes qui peut le faire donc là il y a
quelque chose de compliqué à gérer et
puis il y a aussi et ben le
positionnement de de la Russie ça c'est
la grande de la part d'anglais de
Turquie vis-à-vis de la Russie ou elle
n'applique pas les sanctions elle fait
du business à avec avec la Russie les
oligarches ce sont là alors certes la
Turquie a aidé à la conclusion d'un
accord sur le blé à aider à la
libération d'un certain nombre de
prisonniers mais sa position est quand
même très ambivalente et Agathe
énormément les Américains et les
Français aussi pour dire la vérité et là
il y a quelque chose de compliqué à
gérer pour l'avenir vous voyez une
position qui est à l'apparence d'un
entre deux d'un même temps presque je
dirais mais qui est quand même nettement
favorable à Moscou notamment en bloquant
l'entrée et l'accession de la Suède dans
l'OTAN
erdoğan dès le soir de sa réélection à
redit que ce blocage continuerait
un dossier qui fait au dessus de la
pluie du côté d'Erdogan c'est l'adhésion
ou pas de la Suède à l'OTAN ils sont
arrivés très vite là un levier encore
une fois dont il va continuer à user
donc ça ça ne va pas changer parce qu'il
a été réélu je crois que sa politique
elle a été annoncée assez clairement
pendant que les dirigeants du monde le
félicitaient dimanche soir
er on était au balcon ne sont pas là et
le discours était très clair nous ne
respecterons pas les décisions de la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
nous ne libérerons pas cela est une des
mirages le leader kurde qui est en
prison depuis 7 ans maintenant et il
appelait même ses supporters réclamer la
peine de mort contre lui dimanche soir
donc que les dirigeants occidentaux se
félicitent de la réélection d'erdon
effectivement on peut quand même
s'étonner de les voir aussi satisfait de
voir les valeurs européennes piétinées à
ce point
s'est rendu un peu incontournable sur la
scène
géopolitique
avec cette attitude des principaux
leaders oui c'est rendu incontournable
incontournable en lui permettant de
disposer de ce levier sur les migrants
notamment 2016 on lui a effectivement
donné un certain nombre d'atouts dans
son jeu dont il se sert aujourd'hui
contre l'Europe et effectivement que
vous évoquiez Ariane Bonzon se feront
antioxydantal donc Russie Chine la
Turquie en fait partie à vos yeux
aujourd'hui oui c'est assez clair enfin
il a passé sa campagne à faire campagne
contre l'Occident l'Occident était le
repoussoir la manière pour lui de
fédérer les forces autour de sa personne
donc je crois qu'il y a aucun doute sur
le sujet oui
la Turquie est devenue Observateur a été
accepté comme observateur dans
l'organisation de Shanghai comme vous
savez qui est un organisation qui n'est
pas l'équivalent de l'OTAN évidemment
mais il faut pas exagérer mais c'est une
organisation antioxydante
en fait c'est une sorte de club des des
pouvoirs autoritaires grosso modo c'est
enfin le temps on peut pas avoir un pied
dehors et un pied dedans alors la
Turquie va rester longtemps la Turquie
va rester dans l'OTAN mais c'est le seul
pays de l'OTAN qui est en même temps
membre de observateur dans
l'organisation qui est un peu rivale
désormais donc du coup ça montre bien
toute l'ambivalence de la peau du
positionnement par rapport à Suède la
Turquie va avoir probablement à négocié
avec baiden par exemple le
renouvellement la modernisation des
avions F16 baidan vient hier d'annoncer
que quand il a discuté avec
erdouane elle doit lui disait la Suède
et pardonne baiden lui disait la Suède
le disait F16 c'était ça le résumé donc
il y a un deal permanent il utilise elle
donne c'est un
au sens propre du terme peut-être un
marchand de tapis ou il va dîner surtout
il n'a pas de principe moral sur on ne
va pas traiter les immigrés comme
comme chantage élément de chantage par
exemple il va vous parler de des
immigrés notamment trois millions et 4
millions 3 millions et demi à peu près
aujourd'hui en Turquie ils sont en
Turquie et il a promis et probablement
ça va être ça va être mis en place parce
qu'il a senti que même son électorat
désormais devient de plus en plus contre
la présence des immigrés syriens
malheureusement l'opposition a mené une
campagne un peu raciste sur cette
question là et probablement il va mettre
en place une politique de retour des
Syriens il envisage de les de faire
revenir un million de Syriens
volontairement en Syrie en faisant quoi
en construisant des des des villes dans
les territoires
occupés par l'armée turque ce qui fait
que le problème
sirano turc va devenir un problème
éternel puisque les Syriens vont
demander aussi que l'armée turque soit
retirée de cette place mais les Syriens
qui vont venir ils vont demander la
protection de l'armature nous sommes
rentrés dans une problème
insoluble syrien turque comme un peu le
problème chypriote il reste une minute
parce que ce problème se double du
problème kurde qui est fondamental c'est
à dire que vous savez que la Turquie ne
peut supporter l'établissement d'un
corridor cure d'autonomes au nord de la
Syrie donc si elle veut négocier avec
Assad à sa demande que l'armée sur se
retire de ce nord de la Syrie ou
pourtant elle essaye de laminer si je
puis dire toute la résistance cure mais
en tout cas tout l'autonomie qui ont
donc là ça fait c'est un coup de
milliards à quatre boules quoi il y a de
tous les côtés on ne sait pas qu'est-ce
qui va l'emporter sur pour la solution
du problème quoi on regardera avec le
plus grand intérêt ce qui se passerait
du côté évidemment dans la Syrie dans
les mois qui viennent avec cette
réduction de recettes tu es hyperdogan
merci vraiment un grand merci à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce débat doc
aujourd'hui pour évoquer la situation
politique intérieure et géopolitique de
la Turquie après cette réélection de
récepté hyper de Gan à la tête de la
présidence turque vos réactions ça sera
sur hashtag débadoc sur Twitter bien
entendu merci à celle massali qui comme
à l'accoutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission je vous donne rendez-vous pour
un prochain débat doc et ça sera bien
sûr avec son documentaire et son débat
très bientôt merci
[Musique]